mein eigentlichen Thema richtig tippte
er angeblich die Zustimmung des sog
und die werden jetzt zum großen Teil
aus Japan eingeliefert
neben Aldi zitierte Rallye Aktivitäten
so ist
kann man lediglich den Nachrichten oder
kommen irgendwelche Krankheiten haben
japanisches ist
um würde mich mal interessieren
der Branchenführer schön
würde ich jetzt für
auch nicht Essen
aber der Fisch der hier importiert wird
Prozent geht durch Kontrollen
dort werden immer wieder Stichproben
Messungen gemacht
und schon
insofern
glaube ich nicht dass der Fisch hat der
bei uns ankommt
tatsächlich ein
radioaktive es ist auch nicht so dass
Besuch schlimmer
aus japanischen frisch gemacht hat das
ist nur die Zubereitungsart
insofern darf man das nicht verwechseln
insgeheim hofft Nordsee frisch
oder sonst ein Fisch
ausziehen
ein nach Wege Chen
relaxt suchten seien also dass um
insofern könne sich daran nicht hält
das ganz große Problem Prozent
problematisch zum Beispiel in
Deutschland bringen wäre es bayerisches
mit Schweinefleisch zu Essen
m die bayerischen Wildschweine Berlin
m die bayerischen der Saal
und die bayerischen Pilze
beide sind hoch belasteten auch von
Geschirr mir deswegen
wird das die Schweinefleisch ein
ja aus den Wildschweinen auch streng
kontrolliert
und sogar ein Drittel und dass sie
schwanger Fleisch
ist nach diesen Messung nicht verwertbar
das kommt gar nicht in den Handel
und stellt die Einsprechenden Jäger
werden entschädigt können
auch hier gibt es Kontrollen
die sicherstellen
das kein radioaktives Fleisch
auf den Tisch kommt